this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hey minimizers welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life
with less my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists have you
heard of
compulsive decluttering hmm compulsive
decluttering is a
pattern of behavior that is
characterized by
an excessive desire to discard
objects from one's home and living areas
ryan another term for this is obsessive
compulsive
spartanism it's like the opposite of
hoarding
in a way yes and it's the perfect topic
spartanism this is
episode 300.
oh my god i'm just imagining jordan
right now is putting in a this
is sparta and
there's an image of me like kicking you
into the hole and he's super impossible
jordan is that how long will that take
you to do
we have danny here danny can figure it
out i'm certain yeah for sure
anyway i got a text this week you know
people can text us nine three seven
oh boy what is the phone number two two
two four six five four yeah
that goes to both of our phones and i um
we use this little app called community
and
it sends text to both of us and someone
sent this text and
it said love people ride bikes
but the opposite is kind of fun too
[Laughter]
that's good we did a little a little
contest on on twitter and facebook
right before the book came out love
people use things the the book
and we we did love people use
blank and so you can go to our twitter
feed and find this our facebook feed and
you see all these like amazing
yeah like my one of my favorites is like
love people use your turn signal
yeah that's good that's pretty funny
dude uh it makes me i think my favorite
is uh ella what did she say um
love pizza
use things or something like that yeah
that was good so this week on the
minimal episode we're going to talk
about spartanism we're going to talk
about compulsive decluttering on the
maximal episode ryan i've got some
cartoons about consumerism
i love cartoons we've got some surprise
questions for you
as well last week's maxwell episode over
on patreon
was outstanding it was called collecting
is well planned hoarding
so as ryan alluded to the homes of
compulsive declutterers are often
empty it is the opposite of compulsive
hoarding so a few months ago ryan we did
a hoarding episode we talked about the
five
stages of hoarding podcast sean if you
could put a link to that episode
in the show notes and the opposite of
hoarding is not minimalism
the opposite of hoarding is the
inability
to hold on to anything
and so there are all kinds of burdens
with this or just like with hoarding
there are burdens
financial burdens psychological burdens
the same thing is true with spartanism
the financial burden of
the inability to like i mean think about
if you have their inability to hold on
if you can't hold on to stuff yeah well
then you're
constantly having to replace it whenever
you need something i feel like uh
maybe it's a jack no not jack creature
the tom cruise character yes is it jack
reacher yeah yeah who
who holds on to nothing right like not
even his clothes
yes yeah yeah and and the thing about
that is that's out of necessity as a
fictional character
as a spy right yeah right but i imagine
if he had his own home and stuff he
he wouldn't be that same person it's a
sort of utilitarian thing
the problem is and you and i know a few
people who suffer from
spartanism and they once they start
getting rid of the stuff
and all the stuff is gone they start
finding other things to
get rid of as well including close
friends or careers and you find it's
almost a type of sabotage
in a way they're sabotaging these areas
of their life because
they perceive that having anything
in their life is as though they are
clinging to it
but of course you can have things
without
having to cling to those things
it's interesting how man just anything
taken to the extreme
right yes is going to be detrimental and
uh yeah
it's interesting to that we're having a
whole show based around the other side
of
the other extreme uh on the opposite
side of hoarding well i think sometimes
people confuse
minimalism as though it is spartanism or
asceticism
and asceticism might be similar to
at least it apes the form of spartanism
meaning
ascetics they tend to own very little or
next to nothing
they live a monastic life quite often
yeah right
but they've done so intentionally
spartanism in a way
is almost it's not intentional
it's the inability to hold on to
anything
to the detrimental effect of of one's
life it's funny because both
hoarding and spartanism is the inability
to get clear on what's appropriate to
hold on to or to have in your life yeah
and what's appropriate for you
and individually right so there's if you
don't want to do that work then there
are two options you can either hold on
to everything
or hold on to nothing and both of those
are going to lead you down
a path of misery we got some questions
here
let's start with lisa on facebook
hoarding
spartanism must we diagnose everything
maybe some people just like a lot of
stuff
and others don't done ah well the
episode's over
lisa i i tend to agree with you here
sometimes these labels can be extremely
limiting for someone and so yes
if once we diagnose everything if we
stop there
then well it's not going to get us very
far it's like
if you have a vehicle but you don't exit
the vehicle when you get to the store to
actually do what you want to do
these are concepts right and and
concepts tend to be we could call them
constructs even
conventions and a group of people have
decided
here's what spartanism is or here is
what hoarding is
and you can diagnose someone with that
that's one thing
but understanding the problem beneath
that it starts with the concept but then
what is understanding really it has to
do with awareness
seeing something is awareness
understanding is seeing the thing that
you see
in a way and so lisa you're right if
we're simply
throwing up labels for something it's
not very useful
for us however if we can use that label
to really see what is beneath it
because we we bump up against the
limitations of language
then then it can be useful in us
understanding some of the problems that
that haunt us
yeah yeah i mean whenever we have some
kind of
i don't know dissatisfaction or
discontent or like there's something in
our life that is
affecting and uh affecting us in an
extreme way especially when it comes to
our mental health
i mean i think these labels help um but
yeah do we have to diagnose everything
no
right but sometimes a diagnosis can help
us like you said understand
what's really happening inside of us i
think of nature you know birds aren't
labeling anything
right um they're seeing everything
though
you know same with you average animal if
they have a deer is walking down the
street here
there's a new yorker cartoon there
somewhere yeah with birds labeling
things
i'll think about it i'll let you know
next podcast
and and yet they see everything and i
i understand the spirit of lisa's
question here is it disempowering for us
to diagnose everything
yes to simply label someone and leave it
at the label
can do significant detrimental harm but
if that label
brings you to a deeper understanding of
the problem which is what i want to
explore with you today
then perhaps it can be beneficial for
you you know she said maybe some people
just like a lot of stuff and others
don't and i totally accept that and i
was actually thinking today on the
right end to the studio here i'm like
man we are not
in the business of convincing we're not
in the business of like
uh problem solving we're trying to get
out of the advice business we used to be
in that business but we're trying to get
out of that yeah
i mean but you know we are here to share
a perspective to share a story to
different
perspectives two different stories so
you know to to just kind of
agree with lisa here yeah maybe some
people just like a lot of stuff
yes maybe they do yeah and josh and i
are not here to
talk people out of their stuff we're not
here to guilt-trip anyone or judge
anyone
we are just simply here to share a story
the person who likes a lot of stuff
is not a hoarder though because hoarders
are burdened
by their hordes as we learned in the
hoarding episode
oh interesting and so they don't
actually like their stuff
they just struggle with parting from the
stuff or parting with
the stuff the same could be true for the
spartanist
in a way they they it's not that they
like
getting rid of things it's they have
some sort of barrier that blocks them
from having things that add value to
their life
i wonder like for every one spartanist
how many hoarders are there like is i
would imagine
fewer spartans than horde i don't know
though yeah give me an idea
well i've seen some of the data around
it and it is inconclusive
it's certain that there are a lot more
hoarders because
in our culture we have a tendency to
hold on to cling to things
now i don't mean that literally just the
physical things
but all of us have these attachments
that we've
developed which is a nice way to say
clinging in a way right
it could be attachments to career people
to the past to the future that doesn't
exist
we have all these attachments and quite
often those attachments
also manifest in our things now the
difference with the spartanist
is they're unable to attach
to anything which sounds at first
like oh yeah that's what i want to
aspire toward right but an aspiration
toward detachment is not the same thing
as
non-attachment that's what the buddhist
would say yeah um
well there's a difference in like being
willing to walk away from something
and then just you know having a blanket
of i'm walking away from everything
having to walk away
yeah yeah having to write there's a get
two and a half to yeah
yeah and so your willingness to walk
away is
non-attachment and that can be beautiful
it's incredibly freeing yeah
but it's the opposite it's a if you
can't
if you if you're forced to walk away
from everything
then that's not freedom that's a
different type of of
prison yeah in a way and so the people
who don't like to own a lot of things
we have a name for them too lisa they're
called minimalists
and so i thought they're called
minimizers oh yeah yeah
hello minimizers we have a question here
from caroline in houston texas
i'm in the process of decodering and
getting rid of a lot of stuff but i
noticed that
i want to constantly reach for my phone
to make sure that i'm not going to miss
a lead on facebook marketplace or
whatever platform i'm selling my stuff
so how do you properly balance
leaving your phone alone and also
selling your things at the same time
interesting so there's almost like a
gambling thing going on with caroline
right now right right
um and i could see myself falling into
this trap where i've got
a bunch of things up for sale in fact
now that i think about i probably was in
that mindset when i
was getting rid of my my horde uh after
the packing party
because it's exciting to go and check
and see like oh did i make 10 bucks
did i make five bucks i mean it's almost
like pulling a slot machine
but you're well i mean there's already
studies that show that checking your
phone
is like pulling a slot machine but in
this instance you're actually
getting money so it's even more so um
man uh what would your advice be for
caroline
i would have no advice but i have some
observations here i'm in the observation
business
yes yes and and so here's what i've
observed in my own behavior
so we can talk about some of the how-to
stuff mechanically what can you
do yeah right but before we do that
let's figure out why you feel this
impulse to check is it actually
does it have anything to do with the
selling of the items probably not
or if it does that's one minuscule
component of it
what it really has to do with is what
that dopamine hit that you get
that rush the the desire for
pleasure it's pleasure seeking
and so when we get rid of things because
we're seeking pleasure isn't that in a
way that's a type
of you know stage one spartanism we
could call it that you know with
hoarding you had these
these five stages you and i identified
we were definitely stage one hoarders
likely stage two horrors and in some
cases even stage
three hoarders and that's not a judgment
it's just an understanding of
where we were and it's also an
observation that oh
you can change that because not every
hoarder was a hoarder before they were a
hoarder
there was something that happened at
some point that they went through the
stages of hoarding
and i think the same thing can be true
with
spartanism or the inability to to hold
on but we're talking about here
is is constantly checking in fact
the compulsion to check
it becomes man
when you often say that consumption is
not the problem
compulsory consumption is the problem
yeah isn't the same thing true with
checking our phone checking your phone
is not the problem right the pro the
phone can be really useful
the problem is the is when i
i can't not check the phone yeah and so
there are some things i've done in my
own life that have been helpful
in terms of the how once we understand
why you're
doing it quite often that desire to
check it drops
in the first place however setting up
some boundaries can be useful as well so
one boundary i have in my own home
is the phone goes in my junk drawer oh
what a metaphor there right
now it's not the phone is junk but the
constantly
checking it all day every day that's a
junk behavior of mine
and so if i want to check the phone i
have to get up i have to go to the junk
drawer open the drawer
unlock the phone it creates some
additional
friction because we've removed all the
friction we have that 79th organ there
in our pocket all the time
and it is it's just there with us and
it's constantly saying
hey hey hey check me
right and that knock is loud
right because well because that impulse
is within us well why is it there
because we actually do get something out
of it
but it's not anything meaningful it's
just something pleasurable and we talk
about and love people use things
the difference between pleasure and
pleasure seeking versus real joy
and the enjoyment of the moment now you
can enjoy
selling your things but as soon as you
feel that compulsion
to get pleasure from it in a weird way
it removes the pleasurable response you
you would have otherwise had
hmm yeah no i think
you talking about boundaries i mean
that's the first thing that comes to
mind because i'm trying to put myself
in uh caroline's shoes here and
yeah i would have to set up some type of
boundary
whether it's like checking it once a day
or you know twice a day whatever it is
i'm actually thinking back to when i was
doing this
i only got any boundary setup and i was
just constantly checking i got rid of my
stuff like fairly quickly
because i started pricing it really low
um
but uh but yeah i mean if this is going
on for months like i don't yeah i would
have to set up some
type of boundary but i think you're
right man like getting to the why
so like caroline if you can understand
what it is that is driving you
to do this i mean that's really when you
can stop
and catch yourself in that impulse and
at least
interrupt the pattern you know yeah so
so yeah that's step number one is oh man
i'm trying not to give advice here but
it just comes out i don't know
i'm just thinking for myself for myself
step number one would be catch the
impulse
and then from there i would then analyze
or look at the boundaries that i set up
for myself
and see if i could stick to those
boundaries and i'm sure caroline's not
gonna be perfect with it and that's okay
but but stopping that impulses that's
that would be my step number one just
interrupting that so i'm like changing
your state like that's what tony robbins
would say
well what you're talking about here is
the art of noticing which is actually
one of the sections
in in our new book and that noticing
spawns all this new awareness because
you might notice that you're checking
your phone a lot
but truly noticing it will
will change the behavior in a way that
simple behavior change
wouldn't and that's why i'm hesitant to
say well yeah here are the three things
that you should do
right because those three things will
change the behavior
but as soon as you have a reason to go
back to the impulse you're going to go
right back to it yeah but if you truly
understand
caroline then well then the behavior
changes
on its own by the way i'd love to see
you in houston we're gonna be in houston
next month
we've got a tour stop there a lot of
people use things tour we're coming to
20 different
cities united states and canada so
caroline i'm going to send you a couple
tickets we'll have podcast sean reach
out to you send you a few tickets
so that you can attend our houston stop
for other folks listen to this if you
want to check out one of our tour stops
20 different cities go to the
minimalists.com
tour we'll be in orlando and nashville
and la
and chicago and new york and seattle
and vancouver and toronto and a bunch of
other places
texas and the south and the mountain
states will be in denver and phoenix and
so much more the minimalists.com
tour ryan what time is it you know what
time it is it's time for our lightning
round where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to
937-202-4654
one day i'm gonna like memorize that
number and not have to look at my notes
for that
so during the lightning round so ryan
and i do our best to answer questions
for the short shareable less than 140
character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
if you like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maximums in one place
minimal maxims.com
all right we got a question from ariadna
that's an awesome name when does
minimalism turn into compulsive
decluttering or
obsessive compulsive spartanism what
signs do we look for
so here's the thing i think we covered
this a little bit already
but minimalism in many ways
is the antidote to
obsessive-compulsive decluttering or
cluttering
you know you can call it whatever you
want yeah i don't care what ism you it
could be spartanism
it can be hordism whatever you want to
call it is fine let's not get so caught
up in the definition
what we're really talking about is
intentionalism
versus unintentionalism and the
those are the the fundaments of the
problem right
minimalism is a way to intentionally
question the things we bring into our
lives the things we hold on to the
things we let go of
hoarders don't question the things they
hold on to so they hold on to everything
spartanists don't question the things
they let go of
so they let go of everything so here's
my pithy answer for you ryan
the inability to let go is a problem
so is the inability to hold on
you think about when ella is doing the
monkey bars at a playground right
well if she couldn't let go then she'd
stay stuck
right but her hands kept if we put oil
or butter all over her hands
that'd be really cruel it really would
be
she might kind of like it though
strangely but
so i lathered up her hands and coconut
oil right here go to the monkey bars
she she would slide right off yeah and
that's what a spartanist
does they don't realize it but they're
unable to hold on to anything and that
becomes a new problem
minimalism gives us the grip strength we
need
to hold on but also to move on
tweet that podcast sean oh man my my
pithy answer is this a life
without values is an undervalued life
so man when do you know what are the
signs
i can't give you the top 10 signs that
you're a spartanist
i can't give you the top 10 signs you're
order or maybe i could with the wording
thing
but you know it comes down to what are
your values what are your boundaries
that's where you got to start and if
you're in alignment with those
then you could feel pretty good about
yourself but if you have
no uh no values then you have no borders
you have no boundaries
and uh what do we say if you have no
boundaries it's like being on an ice
rink
without any ice skates on it's just
you're sliding everywhere
right yeah right and i think what
happens here is
we get confused we think a minimalist
is a person who must get rid of
everything um
and that's not where we are with this
a minimalist questions the things in
their life
and so i will tell you this that
if i'm holding on to something and it's
not serving me
it's not the thing's fault right
it's my fault for continuing to hold on
to it but if i'm letting go of things
compulsively the things that are serving
me that are enhancing my life
i'm creating new problems for me and for
my family and for the people around me
and sometimes it manifests outwardly
where i start letting go of
friendships careers quitting jobs
saying screw you to the people i love
that's a form of spartanism so you're
doing that to the stuff
but quite often you're doing that to
what matters most
that's the opposite of living an
intentional life
yeah ryan we got a bunch more to talk
about but first what do you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
check them out my name is luke pearson
at las vegas nevada
i had a comment about fitness
i'm reading a book it's called starting
strength it's a very
simple way to exercise for people who go
to the gym
it's often confusing people who like to
go to the gym
it's often hard to minimalize your
fitness routine
so i started to read this book and it's
simple it may not be
it may not be easy but it is very simple
um and
it's implemented a lot of things in my
life my back is more strong
just everything about me is stronger
don't really care about what i look like
but i feel stronger and i feel healthy
you know and i just enjoy working out
but it was so difficult before but now
reading this
book starting strength by mark ripito
just hope that helps definitely if you
go to the gym a lot
it will simplify your life
hey josh and ryan this is stephanie from
san antonio
joshua i believe had
recommended a book by my new favorite
author andy andrews
and it was called the traveler's gift
and
that book is so it's like the bible
uh another bible without the religion it
just
things it tells you exactly what to do
with your life exactly what you're not
doing
and basically tells you that it's all on
you
and that's a really good book that i
recommend to my friends
and i started reading numerous books of
andy andrews
the noticer is another one that's really
good i think a lot of people need to
read it
it's about perception about seeing
things beyond
your own point of view that one was
really good
i also i don't know if you guys
recommended this or if i just happen to
stumble upon it
but there's a book called miracle
morning
by hal i can't think of his last name
but his first name is hal
and it is a step-by-step
you know get out of your funk process
that
you start your warnings at five five a.m
you do journaling you do reading you do
exercising you run your errands
and it's just a it's a way to change
another way to change your life and they
actually have a community on facebook
called the miracle morning community and
there's people from all over the world
all right y'all we have a bunch more
surprise questions this thursday on
patreon that's the
maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast patreon.com
the minimalist but first real quick for
right here right now here's at least one
thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalists so we're going on tour
really soon we've already talked about
that but every monday
i've been sort of practicing i know ryan
is practicing a talk that we're doing
i'm practicing reading and because i i'm
not good at reading apparently
now what i found out is uh on clubhouse
so you go to the minimalist.com
clubhouse every monday in august so two
of them have already happened we got
three more
happening at this point i read an
excerpt from the book and ryan i've
learned some fascinating things about
the book
um some of these passages i'm like oh
yeah
i'm not ready to read that out loud yet
and so this is like a little test ground
in a way
where i've been testing out these
different passages i'm like oh this is
good this is really resonating out loud
people are asking questions about it
people have comments about it
and there are other things i'm like oh
man mid
mid section i'm like i'm going to stop
reading this this one i'm not ready to
read
or it's not the most compelling part to
work at a live event
so i'm testing out all these different
things you can join me for that
dude i'm thinking about when i was like
proofreading the book uh-huh
and how a lot of this stuff's hard to
read yeah it's funny because like
mariah's reading it and i'm like
yes i wonder how hard it is for her to
like read some of these things
right yeah but uh but there are some of
the things where like
yes and there's a particular shame that
can be associated with them and i do
want to read a lot of those
out loud because i i understand that by
by understanding my own shame other
people
will be able to come to grips with some
of the shame they've experienced or
they've picked up
from their culture from yes their
society along the way 100
and so we're going to be on tour the
minimalists.com tour
20 different cities united states and
canada
by the way one other thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists
danny unknown is here yeah let's put a
picture of a childhood picture of him
right here jordan
when he was like five right here yeah
right there
there he is this is a beautiful picture
right here
i was trying to like encapsulate it put
over my face right right
and uh danny is helping us with audio
video stuff he is welcome danny the
latest hire
for the minimalist newest team member
here
with uh with the minimalist how dare him
have nicer hair than me i mean
his hair is nice i can't i can't pull
the i can't pull the pwn
danny pulls it off well though it looks
great it does and uh next week we're
gonna bring on uh emma
and mallory as well you'll get to meet
them
in the coming weeks and months as well
so the team is expanding
well why we're doing so intentionally we
were uh we were recently with dave
ramsey and
he asked what do you guys really want to
do over the next 10 years
and i think ryan said snowboard or
something um
and and i said well i think ultimately
it's about
healing and that
we're at a certain place right now where
we've been able to help a certain number
of people
heal and we're bringing more people on
to the team
not because we want to grow and
never-ending growth and expansion and
what's the profitability and all these
things
no it's about helping people heal and
finding effective ways to reach people
so that they do heal yeah you and i have
experienced a lot of healing
over the last decade yeah and we've seen
a lot of other people experience healing
as well so how
do we get that message out there because
we know the why
at this point we know why we're doing
what we want to do yeah i love
the uh we're in the business of healing
uh
that feels good yeah yeah we sort of
take a hippocratic oath
in a way as minimalists right so ladies
and gentlemen welcome
danny unknown we'll put a link to his
instagram in the show notes you can say
hi
to him over there real quick for added
value this week
i don't have a song but ryan i was
watching a film this weekend
have you seen any terence malik films
ever uh
maybe i don't know like thin red line
he's a director oh yes
okay i know then red line the new world
tree of life
was okay the big one and
i just watched knight of cups and the
best way i can describe it is it
is a minimalist fever dream in a way now
his movies are a bit surreal they don't
really have a plot
i wouldn't be surprised if they don't
have a script
i also wouldn't be surprised if they had
a 700 page script
as well and it's so fascinating so he
made two movies in the 70s
he's now in his 70s but in the 1970s he
made two films and disappeared from
public life for i think
20 years and ever since then no one's
seen him on camera
like oh wow during the making of the
films or whatever but
this film has a christian bale and it
also has um
natalie portman and a few other people
that you would know but there's
something so
i don't even know how to describe it his
the thing i wrote down here is
his movies are like paintings on film or
maybe it's like visual poetry
in a way let's check it out it's uh
there's this
it's just it illustrates our connection
with nature or maybe our disconnection
from nature he does these things with
water
like full submersion and water
underwater shots that are
unbelievable and um just
this is incredible humanity in the film
he has the soaring music the
cinematography is roaming he uses these
wide lenses
even on close-ups he uses these wide
lenses so even if i do a real close-up
close-up of you
still all the people and the
surroundings and nature that's around
you
it's so fascinating how it's
10 minutes into the film i knew it was
my favorite film of all time
wow man i i don't even i want to avoid
superlatives be like oh it's the best
film ever
but for me even 10 minutes in i was like
i had rented it
i immediately purchased it so i'm like
oh this is i've already watched it twice
wow in three days i could see myself
going back and i barely ever watch a
movie more than once
almost never yeah but this was this
wasn't like a movie it was like watching
you you know sometimes you'll go see a
painting a second time
sure and this felt like i was going to
see
a painting a second time it makes me
think of uh
the salvador dali museum yes like i go
to it every
opportunity i i have same and it's
mainly because
it makes me feel weird you know what i'm
saying
like and i don't know what it is about
feeling weird that i like but like
that's why i like looking at several
girls and it sounds like this film
would make me feel weird yeah it's
called night of cups and the
i love the analogy with salvador dali
here because
salvador dali was sort of the most
famous surrealist
and terence malik one might argue his
films are surrealist
but not the same way that like a david
lynch film david lynch films are
very surrealist i've never seen a david
lynch film twice
uh i've seen them all mulholland drive
and blue velvet and yeah
but i've never watched him a second time
it's almost
as though like his films are ninety
percent reality ten percent surrealism
and terence and alex are like two
percent surreal
but in order for to capture that
surrealism there's almost like a hyper
realism that he's capturing as well
through nature there's this longing for
more i'm gonna talk about more stuff
although that's how it manifests in
humans quite often
but we're all longing for like the thing
that i wrote down here is
a glimpse into the beyond and
he captures that in a way through these
banalities of life
it's almost like he just films a bunch
of beautiful banalities and you find
the true extraordinary experience in
everyday banalities
it's like he's filming a dream about the
truth
so the film is called knight of cups
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
my boyfriend is the worst accumulator of
crap i've ever
seen i can't believe mariah wrote in
it's mariah from the past right is it
possible for a minimalist to live
happily with a hoarder what is death
cleaning
and when does it turn into spartanism
how does one know when to stop
decluttering and why do i
struggle with other people's
expectations of what makes
a house a home plus we have a million
more questions for the minimalist and if
you want to hear all that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week
visit patreon.com the minimalist to
subscribe and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app you also get access to all of our
events certain tiers can get
all of our events upcoming events also
past events all the archives
or ask the minimalist anything our
online
community as well of fellow simpletons
over there
patreon.com the minimalist you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter
and instagram at the minimalist come to
one of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
any new minimalist writings that we
publish
for free and if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it